the clock is ticking for congress now to
make a decision on whether or not to
extend
extra unemployment benefits for millions
of americans
right now people receiving benefits get
an extra 600
a week because of the cares act now that
money is set to expire this week
joe muller joins us now live with more
details joe
hey though that money was only supposed
to last to the end of this month now
people who rely on this money that extra
600 bucks
a week say they don't know what they'll
do if this comes to an end
you know so the 600 is definitely very
helpful is marie regosa is a mother of
two she lost her job during the pandemic
with extra benefits she almost makes
what she did before kova 19.
if i would have just made 400 i don't
know it would have been tough
under the cares act people on
unemployment were getting an extra six
hundred dollars a week
that expires july 25th one expert says
without it people will be making
substantially less
to make it through the pandemic people
needed more than that
chris o'leary is the chief economist at
upjohn institute for employment research
he says congress can extend the benefits
but they have to act fast
he thinks benefits will be less it
probably will not
double state benefits because like i
said some states are very low
and other states are very high and they
don't want to have an uneven federal
distribution
but i'm thinking maybe something like
three hundred dollars or four hundred
dollars as the pandemic remains
unpredictable there was a lot for
lawmakers to consider do you let it
expire this next tranche in september is
the crisis going to be over in september
we also have an election coming so this
is a political economy question
thousands like rigosa are waiting to see
what they need to do i do have some
savings
so i'm sure i'll be okay for a little
bit hopefully they figure something out
now o'leary says we should expect to
hear more on this this week and
president trump did talk about this
today
as well he says he is looking into an
extension but he says
it will possibly be about 70 percent of
what it is now
reporting live joe mohler 8 news now